I think it's irretrievable for Rishi
sunat because I think in the eyes of
huge s the electorate the government has
lost the battle over sincerity when he
launched that I will stop the boats
initiative he framed it in terms of
being seen to strain every senu well
partly thanks to Suella we now know he
didn't strain every sinu he bottled the
original illegal migration act she said
we need these notwithstanding Clauses
she said don't take a a punt that the
Supreme Court will uphold the original
High Court ver that Rwanda is legal he
didn't cover either of those bases
there's no plan B again there's this
issue about the quote left of the party
well I I think there there's more than a
hundred conservative MPS who don't want
to leave the echr or even disapply it
and I think out in the country people
understand if if you really want to stop
illegal immigration and be able to
deport illegal migrants there's just
doesn't seem a pathway in which the
conservative party delivers that